previously on the forest
good what about our cave that's what we
need in our life
i'm gonna go to cave let's do that
together everybody huddle up
i'm coming i'm coming to the cabin my
friends a little low on health
yeah you couldn't eat meat there's a
bunch of meats hanging up because that
uh
help you it heals you like maybe
one fifth ah it does
the protein turns out you cannot carry
two logs while pushing a log sled
damn it seems [ __ ] you bounce right
off of that
oh okay i'm here now hello
hey guys wanna load up our log holders
with these logs i brought
from logsville you had long i'll help
thank you do i have to help a little bit
i'm fine i'm doing stuff over here
all right all right all right forget
about it bars here
that's some raw meat i need to cook i
might as well just chuck it on i just
i just turned the fire on i'm basically
just cooking up all the little game that
i
just got yeah who's glumping
what's the glumps i'm getting oh you're
getting
i see stop laughing i'm getting rocks
good we're gonna need when we face off
on the demons in the cave
good do it i'm doing it i'm gonna help
you
twice thank you sir there you go yeah
we're getting this why can't i pick up
this rock
there you go is there anything else you
guys want to make that takes logs real
quick i got some extra lights oh
put them in the hold arena holders yeah
they're full put them in the holders oh
those are
rotten they're probably fine
[Music]
i don't know how long this is going to
be an adventure for but make sure
make sure we got the balloobs stalked
and ready to rock
stocked cocked and ready to [ __ ] stalked
and cocked and ready to
rock my [ __ ] [ __ ] and i don't stalk my
[ __ ]
no hey i made a small rock bag okay cool
i had one rabbit skin
come right back oh [ __ ] rabbit jesus
christ
i got the armor oh no why did i not hit
then
oh it's gone oh it's not gone oh this
freaking rabbit i'm gonna get this i'm
gonna get this song
all right this is the last sled that's
um i was going for the rabbit no that's
a rock oh there it is
oh right in the head oh got you [ __ ]
got you [ __ ]
you stupid rabbit idiot what's the
what's the recipe for a slingshot
uh
[Music]
what get rid of the three it is almost
oh i got it oh my god i'm getting good
with the slingshot guys
dude i am freaking annihilating all the
woodland critters
dude nice they don't stand a chance
nice dude thanks man i don't seem to see
any woodland critters mark have you
murdered them all i
might have you know
i might have murdered them so where do
you aim at with the slingshot
you want to center it between the prongs
uh actually i've noticed it's a slightly
above the prongs is kind of where it
goes but i might be wrong a little dark
i'm having trouble seeing the prongs
what where it's light it's still sunny
out where are you wait it's still so
it's not really a shadowy place it's
starting to really go down yeah man
so should we sleep tonight and then be
ready for cave tomorrow
yeah i think oh yeah i think that's the
way to go
all right oh hey guess what you don't
recover food when you sleep
what a great night's sleep guys can i
just say that
that could have gone better for me
that's what it was a little rough
all right so uh i've got two rocks for
my slingshot
i've got food i've got water and no
armor i think i'm ready for caves
all right man sounds good i can't
believe a garden just takes four logs
i know so cheating no matter how large
it is
this bow i made kind of useless but i
don't made any arrows but at least i've
got
my stick okay our second garden is one
blueberry seed away from being full
all right well now i just need some
deerskins and uh
for what it's nothing it's just not it's
not a baby i got
money from the ground hell yeah yeah man
all right i'm ready to go do we know
where cave is i'm gonna scout out um
find one and we'll follow there was one
on the way to the uh the boat where we
got the turtle shells there was a cave
that way
um i'm gonna look the opposite way oh
okay
i'm not gonna go that way all right
that's clear pretty opposite but gonna
go not that direction
there's probably a map i could look up
online right a map of like uh
cave locations would that be cheating
that's probably not cheating right i'm
gonna look it up wait what
i might be crazy but there might be a
cave
literally
right no across the way oh it was right
oh there you are you're at a cave um
there's apparently a cave
uh right over here there's some tents
hell yeah dude
some humidity our way humie tents
oh they got bibles here it's a very nice
oh they're
in here yeah it's a small gap in here
but uh
it's a cave all right i'm going right in
oh
this is a tight squeeze my dudes this is
uh
so what's in these things is this going
to be fun
good stuff just a lot of good stuff man
a lot of good stuff you guys uh oh it's
dark as balls yeah it's real dark just
go ahead and get my
lighter out combined we do a lot more
light i like that a lot okay
good this is cool this seems like a
place we should be
what is this um that we're stepping in
normal
as [ __ ] yeah man it's gelatinous
i'll take that and i'll take that and
i'll take that and that
and what is this story item over here i
think it's a turd
i think it was a turd i'm not sure it
looked like a turtle but it's a turd
it does look like a turd which way are
we going uh which
which which i think this this way is
further into the cave
if i'm not mistaken so we want to check
out over this way
yeah watch oh well oh there's a weight
here too i'm gonna go in the water
in the water oh come on bob
apparently that didn't work bob that's
not very good water
i barely lost any health i'm fine oh a
bunch of skulls
here for collecting oh my god oh
no scull it up my dog
not it not first not first i want to see
what's going on
oh my god it's dark oh my god
i can't see i can't see which one's up
oh hold on
never mind that doesn't work aim up
squeeze up
[Applause]
we need like flashlights i think okay
you know what
screw that i i do i'm not about that man
oh there's the outfit okay i'm coming
back to you
guys i am not about that i am back to
that campfire that looked nice yeah
i'm cold i'm going we should probably
dry off yeah dude i am so
not about that i think that was pretty
fun i like that though
you can go back any time you want
there's another cave that's uh
the watches are back i got more watches
from them
oh they respawn watches i can't carry
anything oh i didn't even get any
watches before
okay there's another cave um on the
other side of our camp
we're not done what do you mean we're
all the way over here this way what
there's a mark here you can't get out
that easy
how did you find this i walked over here
screw that okay
see you forever i was i was giving a
moment's pause on that one
i was just trying to look at the wall i
didn't realize i was gonna fall um
i guess you just have to fall but how do
we get back up once you fall
uh obviously yeah i'm committing
there's gotta be a bad way to do it it's
gotta be a background i don't know if
this was the right move
wait no this is more water isn't it
better if we all oh no oh my god
oh god no more what about me
[Applause]
wait what's that what is that that's a
zip line
oh to go deeper
you first bob i want to go look the
other way before we commit to that
you're not going down are you no no you
can climb back up no no no
not that way yeah this is the oh no it's
water you there's no way
there's no way i'm definitely gonna
check out what's in here oh my god no
oh my god no oh no this is fine dark
it's fine you don't have to go under you
just swim it's fine
of course you go under it's fine
it's fine could someone turn a law oh my
god
oh this is not i think we're on a dead
end we're fine it's not
can you guys so when someone stay on the
surface and turn your light on and i'm
trying so
desperately to be in the surface i'm
trying
i can't find the exit you're going
generally towards the exit okay we're
good we're good we're good we're good
screw that that's good you guys really
abandoned me with the lights yeah screw
that
i'm cold a win-win i'm cold
i'm cool i don't like the water man i
don't like the water dude the water is
so intense i love it
no no let's hope there's a way out of
here
i'm pretty sure there's not
no that's gotta be i'm just gonna guess
we're totally boned but let's explore
come on this water could be a way out
we'll just have to go
oh hey you know what i didn't bring what
food i got how deep is this
i have blooms i guess but that's not an
efficient thing you're hungry
that's a fish and that's fine all right
before my ass absorbs your head i can't
see inside my is
i was i literally just see your [ __ ]
legs
boys let's go oh my god boys
oh okay we're down okay this is fine
this is fine
flashy down here can i just say that
yeah it's pretty splashy
okay
no no no no chainsaw james what
okay that must be how all these bodies
got disemboweled
oh yes who wants to be responsible for
the chainsaw well don't we all get it
we all get it oh can we each get it yeah
yeah oh my god put that away
[Music]
yeah okay i can't have a light in this
at the same time but if an enemy comes
out i am freaking chainsawing it
i don't care i am not playing around
there's definitely no bad guys down here
right
yeah or like traps or whatever no way
man no way
all right we'll split up that's always a
good strategy okay are you going the
water
i'll stay on the left no it's all
there's we got to explore mark you can't
not go in the water
this is this is a totally fine place to
be yeah i'm sure these lights just lit
automatically
maintained by the next
[Music]
what was that did you hear that
someone was chattering i heard
all right i think i'll go bob's away
where are you going to go bob's way
come my way oh i hear the chattering
mark there's a person coming oh
wait it's going for you wait wait you're
under attack wait there's a person
wait uh going for wade oh my god there's
one on me too i think why did we
actually split up why did we actually do
the splitting
mark come towards us i'm coming towards
you what is it i don't see it
on you it's not you what is that's a
person all right
i'm slingshotting slingshotting what is
it so fast
it oh i hit it i touched it
no way i'm knocking it the hell out get
get dead
get that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah
did it drop a suitcase what the hell i
think it shut out
whoa oh i don't want to be holding this
right now
where is it it's around behind the
suitcase somewhere
okay okay okay i hear it i hear it it's
about
me me me me me me me me oh my god
this hit and run [ __ ] no that's over
here
we just need to catch him we need to
catch him with a good wife he's trapped
his ass get him beat his ass beat his
ass beat his ass
his ass has been beat yes let's burn
these douchebags
screw these douchebags now they can't
possibly come back to life and do scary
spooky things to us
no what was that what was what
there's more there's more there's more
there's more i see
mark we're not close to you we're
catching up today i'm good i got him
cornered
oh my light please all right
i don't i don't like that very much you
know we light can we keep the light
i got light up but put your light on
then what do you mean can we keep mine
my guy refused to use he was the
anti-light i siblings still missing a
fun drink for a fun oh that's
just an advertisement oh we can put
dynamite here does anybody have dynamite
yes actually i think so really what the
hell
you all right yeah um never mind we can
put dynamite here
how does this work i don't know i think
you place it
and oh oh oh oh my god
did you throw it holy [ __ ]
wow wade that was amazing
i'm so proud of you right now oh my god
there's another rope
oh no okay i'll go first this is fine
second oh whoa a slip oh it's a series
of ropes that go down
oh boy gentlemen we are in for a treat
this is the creepiest this is really
creepy
i've been saying that from the beginning
you didn't agree with me i thought it
was a fun goof for a while
it's becoming increasingly concerning
yeah yeah the the going down and not
going up part is what really is starting
to make me question
a lot of them hey guys look there's a
skeleton
and uh you could
oh there's oh i'm finding pictures of of
spots on the island
oh that's interesting is this the exit
oh i doubt it but you first i'm going
baby there you go
if something grabs me pulled me back
through uh
yeah there was a picture or something
back oh [ __ ] okay go get it
all right um this is not the exit
you guys just wait for me all right good
luck
okay oh this looks bad this is
definitely leading to another chamber
with
water in it
water always with the water
wait there's a swooshing sound what is
that is it something moving through the
water
oh no oh babies
there's babies
where are their babies oh they're baby
you guys climb
they're climbing they're climbing in the
rope
i'll smack them when they come up i'm
not afraid to hit a baby i will hit them
there's a flashlight down there oh
there's a dude too all right i'm going
to slingshot this guy because he's
right next to me but he can't reach me i
think thank you don't keep my light on
you guys slingshot
never mind it's going out gotcha
douchebags careful bob you're about to
fall off
i'm fine i'm wait i am moving aren't i
i'm moving yeah you were holding
if i throw a torch down there lit torch
would i be able to keep seeing them
probably
probably how do i craft this torch not
dynamite
dynamite yeah all right well you guys
talked me into it i this might be
awesome this might be the best
thing yet oh perfect look at that yeah
run away you tried
you cursed the babies and i don't hear
any angry screaming
i think you got him i'm going down
two of us go down together bravely okay
all right
i'm ready i'm ready let's take the fight
to him ready kitty in three two one
mount it okay going and sliding and
sliding taking the fight to the taking
the fight to them
where's the fight oh he is big
he's much bigger than he looked from up
there oh he's dead okay
okay definitely the dynamite weakness
yeah
oh this is a big body how am i carrying
this dude
oh this dude hey nice oh these babies
are oogie
i'm making sure he doesn't come back
hold the babies
yeah actually that's a good idea i just
chopped a little nog
it's all good they got sticks going on
down here for days
that is not what you want to see
like oh god don't no it's
two why does it have an adult leg i
don't like that
is that what you'd call an adult leg oh
look at that i guess i have a trophy
guys oh my god
oh no oh
to b or not to b not to b is the answer
oh it's like a projector what is this
oh a pickaxe oh climbing axe
oh [ __ ] oh wait
right there i'm just climbing oh here i
go how do you do that
you just you equip it and then you use
it on the wall
oh look at you guys oh
holy [ __ ] how are you guys you're so
strong
how am i doing this wait this is not a
place we want to be
uh left left left and then down then hit
e to let go
right here yeah yeah man oh my god let
me eat some bloops for a second
dude we could just climb now now who's
crazy for
building an insanely tall log cabin huh
you know i called you crazy oh it's bad
guys
oh i got so many someone's there
run oh my
[Applause]
i think so i don't know oh the chainsaw
god the chainsaw i think i'm very dead
cause i'm being eaten
oh oh yeah i am oh my god oh
back to the plane i'm down oh wait no
i'm not down
oh hey i'm back at the plane oh [ __ ] my
mark my inventory
i survived back to bob okay i
survived okay we're coming bob okay we
are i'm just chilling guys i'm just
chilling god that freaking noise
hey i see your names dudes yeah we're
almost there now coming up on the
explodey cave yeah here it is
then the series of drop-offs almost
there
going through the gap yeah here is a
pamphlet of the chainsaw
yep god damn it all right we're about
hey
hey what up dogs you look so stupid
do i look like a demon from your worst
nightmares or what
oh because you were you were great man
let me actually probably make some bone
armor too raw rabbit why do i why is my
food raw now
my food got undried you got your stuff i
wouldn't complain
how many do you have do you have an
extra or do you just have the one i've
got the rabbit i've got two lizards here
let me uh
whoa delightful wait i just got sick
your meat bed
it looks like we got a climbing wall
here
we need to go up to the right or just
all the way up up right both upright
upright i think
okay got it oh please tell me we're
getting out of this cave
please tell me oh
are these hearts and kitties oh good
oh good i think we're here wait i think
this is oh
i think this rope is out of here sorry
guys i'm i'm
leaving i want freedom and marcus just
what do you mean you wanted this
adventure so bad right now oh they
are kidneys and stuff yeah man let's get
out of here
yeah oh mark we're gonna leave now
you're all welcome to leave now if you'd
like
all right good man i am so glad i let
bob go a little ahead so i'm not inside
of him there oh my god
oh my god watch your stamina boys do you
just
fall off if you don't i don't know i
haven't done it yet i've only come
extremely close
we can find out i'm okay whoa
guys i see someone in the distance
good something i don't know man i think
it's the earth's
butthole oh yeah there is a
what is that there's a pit what where
over there
that way there's just like a the oh
cliff's face
i'm going wow interesting yeah our
health is not doing too hot these days
no we could really use some towels
there's some big guy on the other side
of the
here i'm gonna chainsaw him if he comes
near me
come at me bro man he's just out for
mark there's more than one
yeah well i gotcha oh my
holy crap all right
what is what why
what the [ __ ] is this is this a
graphical bug what is this
what oh my god
i'm not gonna jump it mark jump in not
jumping
you got a climbing thing just jump down
there it's fine no way
come on man no thank you nope i'm okay
well
we have we have you you work wait let me
just test something
this feels like an in-game i don't think
test i don't think we belong here yet
me just test something bob do not test
something bob's fantastic bob fell
into the pin now he is
[Music]
oh i think i'm down
i honestly was not trying to slide off
the side there i'll
mark mark mark mark
she's tough you know i don't think i
could take this much chainsaw
i don't think i could either
well i thought whoops all right bob so
um
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh can you guys stay
there for a second so i can
get back to it i'm hoping they program
something that respawns your bag
like on the edge top edge or something
no probably not
i could climb stuff can we build down
there wait can we build like a one of
those lips
the ropes don't go too deep yeah you
could build a rope and then
maybe a platform uh you'd have to like
bring logs and stuff
i think it's going to be fine guys i
don't think there's anything to worry
about i think it's going to there's a
bird on this lady
die bird cold man
i'm i'm gonna recover my backpack come
hell or my death multiple times
and don't you even worry about it just
activate no clip mode and just go down
there real quick
i am what a cliff wow
hey i'm on my way
who's being yelling oh you got a whoa
whoa whoa
oh you've got you have ah that those are
oh god mark i'm down how are you down
oh my god oh my god i got a hit from
multiple directions
your chances yeah well i would have if i
had
known there were that many coming all
right you guys keep them busy
oh my god is this this i got very
distracted by a
a pair of screens i'll get weighed up
mark you changed it all i'll get away no
i got him i'm right here i'm right here
mark
oh well
[Music]
all right i'm back again i feel good
fight me
all right guys i think i can do this
[Music]
all right good luck
[Music]
okay got him nice nice nice dead there's
a mermaid
down here guys
but i'm fine it's fine this is fine i
see you in for your inventory did you
get your stuff
no not yet but i will oh there's a
helicopter it's not a mermaid it's not
cutting out trees
what there's a helicopter yeah there's a
helicopter how am i gonna
get out of here guys do you have any
thoughts on that i'm gonna build a
platform i'm gonna try to build a rope
off of the platform
that's good okay try to extend and um
try to like if that doesn't work i'm
gonna build a staircase down
and uh i just gotta go get some trees
you just sit tight there man you sit
tight there we're going
i'm at a point where if i let my health
tick back up because i took medicine
i can i can make this next jump and get
my stuff back
okay okay okay i love that i love that
so like i'm close this is
everything is almost back to normal it's
fine how many more we need
31. okay i got to build a sled
geez this platform really wanted to
build up oh my god okay
i gotta build a log ski sled
there wait okay i got my backpack back
okay good okay okay and i'm in a safe
ish location okay i just need to find
sticks i got to build this stupid sled
can you put sticks on the thing if you
got them there's literally no
small trees for sticks yeah there's a
little one down here right by the sled
okay
okay i'll equip that
we're at 15 to 21 on sticks i can't
because i
cannot climb oh here we go i guess it
doesn't count
uh-oh uh mark get your chainsaw all
ready i didn't know how to put it on a
hot dog yeah i am way far away man
come to me if you need help but there's
no small trees what
oh i'm down how are you no don't be down
no don't be dead i had no health i got
hit once did you
oh no oh i'll be right there i'll be
right back
it's gonna be okay i found a i found a
butthole on the side of the cliff and
i'm going toward it
okay okay that sounds promising oh don't
slide off don't slide off okay
don't do careful
oh no do i have to dynamite this open no
okay oh yes i'd no i can scooch in
all right i found a cave i can enter
what
the baby the babies are birthing from
the ground
what the what i don't know man muddy i'm
uh
not feeling so hot i'm almost there
i'm almost there guys don't die don't
die gotcha
oh i'm not exactly safe
per se but i'm in a cave right now i'm
no longer like
in the trap that's just in the side of
the pit oh
i can keep stand behind me and save my
game well i'm definitely saving my game
whoa what the hell far behind his butt
oh you're like oh my god
oh my god i got him i got him you just
you're a wizard
i got him i got him you're a wizard
harry
there we go i just climbed up a rope and
now there's water
oh goodness oh no well we're gonna keep
i'm gonna keep working on this uh this
um other strategy
if it works yes yes yes yes i'm gonna
build a camp this is good
this is going over here no no no no no
oh no all right well
mark you okay there
[Music]
you